je mehr Elektroden ein brain machine
Interface besitzt desto besser kann man
damit z.B Computer oder Prothesen
steuern oder Informationen auslesen
deshalb will nuralink die Anzahl der
aufnahmekanäle ihres BMI natürlich
maximieren mit 1024 aufnahmekanälen ist
es gleich auf mit dem aktuellen
Forschungsinstrument dem Uta Array
nuralink will diese Anzahl sogar auf
unglaubliche 16 000 erhöhen der Haken
ist nur bisher kann nuralinks BMI nur 64
dieser Kanäle gleichzeitig verarbeiten
und diese enorme Daten arbeitung auf dem
Implantat erzeugt Hitze die dem
empfindlichen Gehirn schaden könnte
neuralink macht also gute technologische
Fortschritte hat aber auch noch einige
Herausforderungen zu meistern ich bin
sehr gespannt was da noch kommen wird
die Richtung ist aber auf jeden Fall
klar